[Music]
oh my god you know i had to do it bad
like my women like my check so make sure
that it's there keep it real and make
them stand out like comedienne
standing ovation they want me to do it
again i guess that depends on my way
hope you know i came to get it
[Music]
with the savages i just pulled out of
the back of the club make the whip
disappear like a magic trick how could
you even be mad at this i do not see
what the challenge is i had to learn how
to balance it now so cold and so callous
but i came right back again i had to get
to the back again
[Music]
mike what up baby good to see you man yo
what's up good hey i'm here with brows
what up big fan
thank you bro i'm a bigger fan um i see
the merch daddy what's up just came in
doug this [ __ ] is fly can't wait to rock
it look like me uh we need your uh
footage for the music video we're
shooting right now literally in the
middle of it and we're just waiting on
your footage so yeah
you know get it done again and the
videos that's not going to work i can
send it next week i'm actually
rehearsing now for tour
yeah what
was the terrible i did that's stupid
yeah you know what you know what i got
this i got it i'll take it what do you
mean you got this
okay i saw this in my head
now i'm in every night even paying rent
yeah i grind it for a minute used to
hate to go to bed sleep like i'm dead
cause i make money
[Music]
you know i had to do it big
like my women like my check so make sure
that it's there keep it real and make
them stand out like comedian
standing ovation they want me to do it
again i guess that depends
[Music]
[Applause]
you